I started a new caption contest with
this picture of Magnus the dog and Sassy
the cat curled up cuddled up however you
want to put it together this was kind of
a common sight back when both of them
were with us and this is here in the
apartment on their favorite bed a yogi
bow and it's kind of hard to tell
exactly what Sassy's expression would be
I know what it is
um but you know some people might think
oh look at that poor little kitty cat
actually she ran the place and uh Magnus
was adopted as a puppy when sassy was
already uh you know a young adult cat
along with her sister Teensy so she's
actually running the show there but got
a lot of good captions for this here the
first one making reference to the
Chinese diagram you could call it and
Cosmo logical concept of inyang cat dog
it kind of fits kind of looks like
they're
you know blended into each other in that
sort of way and I kind of like the idea
of complementarity with these two as
well because they were favorites for
each other uh here's the next one well I
always feel this way so cuddly so
embraced and the notes make me think
that this is perhaps from some song that
I don't actually know
um and they did like to cuddle up with
each other a lot they did that pretty
frequently here's the next one and now
we start to see a shift in the
interpretation of what's going on they
say you should get a full 56 dog hours
of sleep every night get the best sleep
of your life on a Tempur-Pedic pillow I
don't know okay so that's pretty good
you know Sassy's being used as a pillow
there and you see the reference to dog
hours sort of like dog years we say that
every year of a person's life is like it
translates no every year of a dog's life
translates into seven years for them so
it has a decent joke there here's
another one pillow oriented why bother
with a pillow you are the perfect pillow
for me and you know it's kind of funny
because it wasn't that unusual to see
sassy laying on top of the dogs as well
using them as a pillow or a cushion
here's the next one uh nice color yup
also my favorite this one's a little bit
what would you call it not perplexing
but confusing
um both of them are liking the gray of
the yogi bow cushion that they're on
perhaps I'm not sure what the dialogue
is supposed to be about but I think it's
kind of funny nonetheless and then we
get another uh similarly funny one have
we had enough quiet time yet dad and I
guess this is referring to Magnus
looking up at me as I'm taking the
picture as if you know the two of them
have been put into quiet time and now
they can actually get to do something
then here's one that I don't have any
idea what it's supposed to refer to in
the picture I'm sorry I ate your dinner
too I'm not sure if it's supposed to be
Magnus having eaten Sassy's dinner or
sassy having eaten magnus's dinner much
more likely is Sassy actually eating the
dog's food which once she discovered how
tea tasty it was we would sometimes let
her have a little bit and we had to keep
her out of it and then we get when the
conscient kitty meets the care ethicist
so now we're starting to get a little
bit philosophical right not sure why a
cat would be conscient of any sort of
thing but the idea I suppose is that
Magnus is like the care ethicist giving
her Care by cuddling up with her
we get another one kind of along the
same lines
that references the meaning of existence
right a little bit of misspelling here
as well they're there my child the
meaning of existence isn't so bad after
all and I guess it's supposed to be
Magnus consoling sassy or something like
that and perhaps it's misspelled because
it's a dog and they can't really spell
that well
and then finally the last and best one
um my friend Allison McCone hands off
Schrodinger you're never putting my cat
in a box she's all mine so we'll live in
my mind forever and uh yeah so I mean
this works on a lot of different levels
right if you're not sure what
Schrodinger is doing there well it's the
famous cat in a box experiment
um where Schrodinger wants to
potentially poison a cat with gas but
you're not sure whether the cat is alive
or dead until you actually open the box
and this could be Magnus saying this to
Schrodinger could be me as well uh she's
living I mean both of them are living in
my mind and heart forever so that's kind
of a cool one to close on we'll be doing
more of these caption contests videos
down the line
um I'm sure I'll post another one before
too long and if you want to get in on
this you can make sure to you know check
the community tab you might want to turn
on your notifications so that when there
is a new one posted you get to see it
right away I do also post them in my
social media but you got to leave your
comments on the YouTube Community post
and that's all I've got for this one